بين هذه الخطوط والعاصمه كييف يدور شك في
قدره الاخيره على شن هجوم مضاد في الربيع
كما قالت وتتحضر
فعام من الحرب انهت جيشها وافقده الافا من
ذوي الخبره القتاليه
في احدث التقارير الغربيه فان حاله القوه
العسكريه الاوكرانيه متدهوره بسبب حجم
الاصابات التي اخرجت العديد من المقاتلين
الاكثر خبره من ساحه المعركه
يرجع مسؤولون اوروبيون وامريكيون حاله
التدهور هذه لعده اسباب
فخلال عام وقع 120 الف جندي اوكراني بين
قتيل وجريح جلهم من ذوي الخبره القتاليه
حجم الخساره هذا دفع كييف للدفع بمجندين
عديم الخبره لسد النقص على خطوط القتال
اضافه للنقص الاساسي في الذخيره
وفقا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست فان الاشهر
القادمه تشكل تحديا امام كييف لاستعاده
زمام المبادره وشن هجوم في هذا الوضع الذي
يعاني فيه جيشها من نقص في العدد والعتاد
بالمقابل فان حال الجيش الروسي ليس بافضل
حال وان كان عدده يشكل ثلاثه اضعاف جيش
اوكرانيا
فوفقا للتقديرات الغربيه ذاتها فقد خسرت
موسكو قرابه 200 الف جندي بين قتيل وجريح
اضافه لمشاكل في الذخيره والقوى العامله
وما بين تشكيك بقدره كييف وموسكو على
الهجوم والدفاع فان التقديرات تقول ان
عاما من الحرب انهك الجيشين وان عاما
جديدا بدا لتوهه ايضا بالحديد والنار